So to use an API, you generally have
to go through a couple of steps.
Typically, you have to sign up for
an account with the service,
if you don't have one already.
You have to register
the app you're making.
And later on, in order to make requests,
there's usually some sort of
authentication process involved.
In order to keep this setup simple for
now,
our Sleeping in the Library app
is going to use the Flickr API.
Unlike other similar services, Flickr's
API allows us to bypass a few of
the normal set up steps, requiring
us to only sign up and register.
We'll cover the parts skipped,
namely the authentication flow,
later in the course.
Signing up for a service like Flickr or
Yahoo is pretty straightforward, so
let's talk about registration.
When you register an app, you're usually
given what's called an API key and
sometimes additional keys as well.
That are used to uniquely
identify your app.
The reason for a service to want to
uniquely identify your app is so
that they can detect requests
coming from your app and
protect against apps that
are making too many requests.
This allows the service to ensure apps
don't do harmful stuff, like say,
flood the network with so many
requests that their server shuts down.
So you can see why these identification
keys would come in handy.
So let's get started using our API.
You'll want to sign up for a Yahoo
account if you don't have one already.
I know this part may be
a little bit annoying, but
trust me this does
make our lives simpler.
Click create an app,
then you'll want to get your API key.
You want to click non-commercial, since
we don't plan on making any money off on
pictures of people
sleeping in the library.
You'll then fill out these two fields,
and upon submitting,
you'll receive a key and secret.
I'm going to call this
Sleeping in the library.
Copy these two values and
paste them somewhere safe.
You'll need them soon.
Lastly, you'll want
to take some time and
look around
the Flickr API Documentation.
This will give you an idea of some
of the methods that you could
potentially use.